I would much rather have a tiny role in
an awesome movie than to be the head guy
in something that's just
training day I was doing security for
years in Hollywood and I had a friend
who was part of with a location manager
because that's what they would do they
would do the locations and it would need
security well he's like dude we're doing
this really intense movie at the jungle
right now with Denzel Washington
you gotta come check it out I came on
set as a visitor I always realize that
you just have to go like if you just
show up a lot of times your
opportunities are there I was watching
them self prepare and I was studying him
and I was like this is how an actor at
the top of his game does his thing or
the director walks over to me Antoine
Fuqua and he says hey man you want to be
in this movie I said yeah I was like
sure whatever you need me to do it was
WOW
he said look I want you to take your
shirt off it says the Sun is going down
I'm gonna get you up on the roof and I
want you to flip some pigeons and the
whole I was like okay whatever took my
shirt off I went up on the roof of his
house and he said Terry come back every
night for the next week and he said I'm
gonna find ways to use you in the movie
and I was like whatever you need and I
didn't get one dime for training day I
just showed up I volunteered I said
whatever I can do
I just want to help the movie I want
this to be the best thing ever
oh you [ __ ] okay
I remember when when when the scene got
played at the Oscars my mother called me
just screaming like yeah the Oscars I'm
like no I'm not I am NOT at the Oscars
mom I'm in the Oscars but I'm not at the
Oscars this is thing a small role like
that I was so happy to be a part like I
cannot describe to you to satisfaction
of being a movie that good you know to
me it's that iconic and forever and ever
now at the time that was gonna be my
career trajectory I was going to be the
heavy I was going to be the mean guy in
the movies and that's the way everybody
was seeing me at the time there's a
stereotype about big muscular
african-americans that make you security
guards there like he's big he's me or
rip you to shreds and I wanted I love
the fact that I have killed that trope
and you have to see us as real people
three-dimensional happy family and I'm
happy to be one of those guys that
provides that now
Friday after next I actually did
security on next Friday
I remember watching cubes car and his
trailer and I was like good morning mr.
cube and he'd be like yeah I may get out
the way oh my god I thank you and what's
wild is this is before I was acting I
started acting and did a show called
battle dome and they did another movie
called the 6-day and then I was an extra
in training day and they recognized me
from that cuz you know training day was
one of the ice-cubes favorite movie but
they remembered me so I got a chance to
audition for Friday after next and I
remember sitting in the waiting room me
and Kat Williams hoping praying one day
we would be able to you know be in this
movie Katt Williams and I decided we
were gonna go all in there was gonna be
no holding back you look at the scenes
with Katt Williams and I'm it's almost
like a intense drama you're not and it's
really really interesting to to bring up
the the me to aspect of this thing
because it was comedic but yet here I
was this guy who was sexually assaulting
[Music]
at the time it was beautifully big
comedy when you look back at it in a new
light you can almost see it it's like oh
my god like this this is really the
attitude of you know when you're talking
about male-on-male assault the attitude
about this thing was comedic and tonal
which has made it really really hard for
men to be believed and I think about it
now in retrospect and you kind of go
that's really it's deep you know even I
was a part of that at the same time I
think when Kat and I were doing it we
wouldn't play it as a comedy and this is
why it worked in a lot of ways when I
look at Kat and his career and how he's
gone and what it did for me people say
this guy is willing to be a true actor
and put it on the line and because we
were we were playing it as if it was
dramatic I remember I had the two fox me
you know a lot of people to this day
like you ruined that song for me man you
ruined it but what's so great I remember
being on the set and just I had a little
bit and I started dancing and they were
like keep it going keep it come on keep
the film rolling keep it going this is
what I learned to go ahead and do it a
lot of times as actors a lot of times
when you're doing things you go well you
know they may not use that so I won't do
it and then you you missed an
opportunity Terry Crews will never miss
his opportunity white chicks
Damian wins we said man I gotta
introduce you to my uncles I kind of
introduce you to my uncles and all that
okay cool cool and he said they got this
movie coming out we think you'd be right
there was one day I had an audition for
wife and kids and I thought I was gonna
do it and I bombed it I mean it was the
worst audition ever I was like man I
wouldn't pick me my agent at the time
told me you have another audition for
another movie it's white chicks and I
went and just blow it was like and this
is the same day right after a bomb you
don't care anymore you stop caring and
you just go and Keenan was like wow this
is pretty good I thought maybe he's
being nice because I'm a friend of his
nephew you know I mean I said okay cool
I get the job
I'm in Vancouver and let me tell you
something
Keenen Ivory Wayans these are the
Jacksons of comedy this was the the
iconic Here I am the great Keenen Ivory
Wayans and he's like Terry whatever you
did in an audition he said do whatever
you want to do for my I just like
whatever he said man it's your I ran
with it I have never ever that was the
first time I was fully confident as an
actor I did that Vanessa Carlton 1000
mile song in the car
one take
making my way downtown walking fast
faces pass and I'm home bound
and every scene I was in was just
comfortable and following and then the
premiere happened and my life changed
forever the the producer of the movie
called me he said Terry your life will
never ever be the same
he said that you stole this movie all
out I was like oh my god
it was incredible bureaucracy we had
just wrapped white chicks and I was
auditioning what was weird is that I
kept auditioning like I had an audition
for this movie probably seven different
times which is really unusual usually if
you get a callback
it's cool you know and you might get two
or three at the mo for me to go in there
so almost seven times I was like what in
the world
I remember what Mike just said you got
the gig the casting director Mary Renu
she said Terry if I told you who and how
many other people were going for this
gig you would be intimidated she was
like you wanted
and she's like there were some big big
names going for this president role and
I was like oh my god they were like and
but Mike wanted you that's why we kept
calling you back I knew this guy would I
tell you I knew president Camacho
because this really reminded me of my
time of growing up in Flint Michigan in
church where you had a pastor or a
preacher who you knew was a hustler you
knew he wasn't telling you the truth but
he can say it was so much charisma if
you just put $5 in the box $5 will get
you what's your wall he's fooling
America I said this is the biggest
bombastic personality he's a wrestler
he's an ex-porn star he's a he's a
charismatic person who's just bigger
than life and he wants to he wants to
run the world and I tell you I went in
again it was one of those things when we
did the speech and I was like he don't
oh you know I was doing all of those
stuff
[Applause]
[Music]
my judge was like dude this is it I lost
myself and when you lose Terry Crews and
you become you know this this you know
president Dwayne Elizondo Mountain Dew
Herbert Camacho I said this is this is
my life and what was so disappointing is
that it was a bomb I was telling
everyone this is the big one Maya
Rudolph that Shepard all these got
Stephen Drew my judge it's gonna be
great to creator of eNOS and Butthead
and the rumor was is that we you because
we use real corporations in our comedy I
mean Starbucks was giving hand jobs and
these companies gave us their name
thinking never gonna get pumped up and
then when I welcome to Costco I love you
welcome to Costco I love you all these
real corporations are like wait a minute
wait a minute well Carl's jr. would you
like to try our there are a lot of
people who are like backing out but it
was too late and so Fox who was the who
owned a cup the movies decided we're
gonna release this and it's few theaters
as legally possible so we got a release
in probably three theaters over one
weekend and it was sucked out into the
Vortech years later I had major major
stars coming up to me and going Camacho
oh my Will Ferrell was like that
performance blew me away oh my god
people that I admired and loved for
years were like idiocracy is my jam
[Music]
The Longest Yard I like to call the
longest shot my revenge on the NFL I
heard that there was this new movie
longest char and I'm waiting for other
roles that I met with their director
Pete Siegel as where can I be what can I
go and they didn't know where they were
gonna put me well they had a role for
Cheezburger Eddie now originally
cheeseburger Eddie was supposed to be
400 pounds that was the joke the joke
was he eats cheeseburgers he's a big big
guy Adam said wait a minute
what we're gonna do we're gonna make you
cheeseburger Eddie but you're gonna be
in shape in fact it's like cheeseburgers
make you more muscular he was like and
you are gonna be hustlin this
cheeseburger this McDonald's is
contraband in our art our prison and
number two this is the biggest
production I had ever been on today you
had wrestlers from a WWE you had
comedians Chris Rock and you had all
these stars here I was in Santa Fe and
I'm not oh my god I am cheeseburger Andy
I remember putting on my little knit cap
and I Chilton it to the side and I knew
that's who I am when I started pulling
those cheeseburgers out and I saw the
reactions from everyone and the way and
I treated goes beginning I never treated
like it was a comedy I was really really
like going at it as I am in prison and
this is as good as cocaine or drugs or a
woman you want a little taste of the
outside I knew to really come at it that
way and let me tell you a week doesn't
go by and people you go to cheeseburger
and then I reach for my pants and it's
like
Everybody Hates Chris came from being on
the set of the longest shot Chris took
notice of me
he said he noticed that I was a father
he noticed you know cuz I had my kids on
set I was bringing up and I hold would
think he also and this is the thing when
I tell you people are watching you he
also noticed how I was around other
women and around other people and he was
saw that he was like this dude is about
his family he said I got something for
you now I was at home probably about
three weeks later I get a script no
heads-up no warning no nothing open it
up and it says Everybody Hates Chris now
I'm laughing already because the show
Everybody Loves Raymond was already on
the air and I was like Everybody Hates
Chris hilarious just just that joke when
I open it up it was one of the funniest
thing I ever read in my life 30 pages of
pure gold and I was like oh my god now I
wanted it I was the first guy higher on
that show Everybody Hates Chris took
over that year the buzz was good
everything was great and it was four
wonderful seasons of being this
wonderful african-american dad I Julius
and the only character named after a
real family member because that's how
much Chris's dad meant to his comedy and
I mean to play such an iconic character
in his life and for him to trust me with
that Chris has other brothers and
sisters that are like man thank you
thank you for representing our dad the
way you did I mean I get a little choked
up these are real people were talking
about you know his father died before he
could see all of his success and when I
look at everybody is Chris now I'm
beyond proud
The Expendables The Expendables the
first movie was supposed to be
direct-to-video you understand where
Stallone was at the time he was trying
to get this thing done that I do in your
sixties
how are you gonna do an action movie all
the studio's turned it down so sly
starts calling people and he starts
getting the buzz going and this is also
in the first days of Gooding viral
energy on the Internet
so what slice started to do was tweet
out how would you like to see me Arnold
Schwarzenegger Bruce Willis and a movie
together and the internet went crazy and
then he called me now listen I was
probably the fourth choice in the movie
to be honest but okay fourth in the
world is okay me I was like and I got a
call and I met sly in his office and he
was like it was a good I doing there I
need you for the movie right we're gonna
do this thing and I'm thinking it's an
audition he's telling me we're shooting
in about three weeks and be ready and
I'm going like I got like I mean I'm in
the movie and he was like yeah you're
the movie we're done well there you go
we get ready about three weeks get your
bags back okay so there I am I'm in
Brazil gently comes in Jason Statham
comes in Randy Couture Dolph Lundgren oh
my god yeah if every time in Bruce
Willis Arnold Schwarzenegger and sly and
Here I am and it took over it was the I
remember when at the summer it came out
it was so manly
people were like be careful you know
you're gonna get pregnant if you watch
this movie it was like the manliest man
late movie of all time what I was on the
movie set I was very disappointed I
remember I didn't feel like I was being
used enough I've wanted to do more and
they were like no and I got a bad
attitude this is the moment in the road
the fork in the road where I was like
always giving all I had showing up for
free no problem into I want my money and
then I remember sitting you know I
remember I think it was some kind of
quote that I heard it was something like
you know there is no way to happiness
happiness is the way and all of a sudden
I said you know what Terry
change this is I'm telling you man this
is what happened it was literally in my
room it said tomorrow
act like you're getting twenty million
dollars I started to shift my attitude
when people go hey Terry I'll go hey how
you doing how are you hello everybody
what do I need to say they say one line
I would go out say my line and give my
all just like I did when I when I
started out just like on training day
all of a sudden so I started to notice
and let me tell you something he we
wrote the script the script in the
original script
there was no tunnel scene he rewrote the
script he said Terry you're gonna save
my life and I remember coming through
that tunnel with that with my big you
know a a 12 shotgun and I'll bum bum bum
bum bum and I ended up saving the whole
crew it's one of the iconic moments in
the movie where everybody literally I
when I watched it in the theater
guys were jumping up like yeah oh you
know and he gave me a moment I killed
maybe 30 people at once probably in the
course of like 10 seconds I kill like 45
people and then I said to the conic line
more like yeah and I was like all
because I shifted my attitude and I
changed my trajectory I think everything
could have went wrong at that time in my
life that fork in the road but it didn't
did I learn forever and ever
be the solution don't be a problem on
the set
don't be the issue cuz you know what the
job is hard enough you know what I mean
and I don't need you don't need to be
the one making things harder and I knew
that that was gonna be my key and it
sure was Expendables with a giant hit
and it made me truly a worldwide star
bridesmaids
wow that was a Judd Apatow Kristen Wiig
got a call cuz they were like hey we're
looking for his just fitness trainer and
you know we got this joke here we want
to do it was a one day thing I am a
Kristen Wiig fan we actually did an
episode of drunk history together
everything she does she goes and see I
can respect that because I'm the same
way she does her comedic things as if
she was doing drama and when we were
able to do do this stuff in bridesmaid
and Maya we just started out living and
just started going and they're over
there and at redoing their workouts and
I'm like what y'all do you know I
remember to see the scene how I would
feel if you saw somebody jacking your
workouts you know I mean it was one of
those cameos again like I said I would
much rather have a little part in a
gigantic movie and it was gigantic what
I said when bridesmaids hit I had no
idea how big that would be I mean it was
enormous and again I'm proud to be a
part and honored to be a part of that
whole thing it's like being a part of
Hollywood history
[Music]
sorry to bother you
I've met with Nina bon jovi who is
Forest Whitaker's producer and they said
we're doing this new one sorry to bother
you with boots Rolly I've been a big fan
of boots since the cool and I said let
me see the script and I started reading
and I was like it started out pretty
good and then it went off the rails and
the spirit went bonkers like oh my god
did I was like I have to be a part of
this he started talking about the
character started talking about what
Sergio was and here he's this uncle and
and perceived Oakland and Flint Michigan
I like sister cities and I'm from Flint
I knew Sergio because he reminded me of
so many people that I grew up with who
had kind of traded in theirs
their dreams for the security of a
factory and all of a sudden have that
factory just just totally jerk you and I
was like man I know Sergio I lived
around Sergio I know these guys to be a
part of this thing it was one of those
things where I was like again small role
but big big impact let me tell you when
I got done when we got there I was like
dude this is gonna be groundbreaking
when I saw it at Sundance it reminded me
of the first time I saw do the right
thing and you just go man this is gonna
change the game this is the movie that's
gonna influence all the young filmmakers
of color for the next 20 years
Brooklyn nine-nine I had got with Mike
Shore and Dan Gore and we had a meeting
and they said we're doing the new Andy
Samberg pilot and I didn't even have a
name and I was like oh I love Andy
Samberg right so I this is one thing I
knew I said Andy is the future of comedy
and I said this is good but there were
some other things Mike and Dan called me
up and they say Terry we have named the
character that we want you to play in
our script Terry so if you don't take it
you are gonna feel horrible knowing that
someone else is walking around with your
name I was like damn it you bastard you
bastard you got me I said my god that
was a very wise move because you're
right I would have felt horrible knowing
that this guy's name Terry and it was
really supposed to be my you know we did
the pilot it felt like we had already
been together five years and lo and
behold we got to pick up and then we won
the Golden Globe that's a whole nother
thing then to go five seasons get
canceled and then have the internet
bring you back from the dead the
internet the internet flips out from
Guerra Guillermo del Toro from
lin-manuel Miranda a mark
Mark Hamill Sean Astin they are flipping
out like we gotta have a booklet nine
nine back the internet flip we were
number one trending all over the world
and it just made me feel so good and
then NBC picks us up thirty hours later
a man you you just you got to understand
something about my life what's so crazy
about my life is this B Road it no one
will believe it
they would say it's contrived they would
say no way this it's to this doesn't
happen
but that's how life is truth is stranger
than fiction